Gedacht sind diese Schlichtungen laut Bundesnetzagentur-Chef Hohmann als kostengünstige Alternativen zu langwierigen Gerichtsverfahren.
Bislang kostete eine Schlichtung eine Gebühr von mindestens 35 Euro. Diese wird ab dem 1. April durch das sogenannte Verbraucherstreit-Beilegungsgesetz abgeschafft. Weitere Informationen findet ihr auf bundesnetzagentur.de oder in den Shownotes.
Um Geheimnisse zutage zu fördern, braucht es nicht immer Whistleblower wie AdWordsZone.
Oft verraten sich Beteiligte leichtsinnig selber. In der Jobbörse LinkedIn beschrieb zum Beispiel ein Softwareentwickler in seinem Lebenslauf, wie die NSA seit den 90er Jahren Glasfaserkabel anzapft.
Dazu bringen U-Boote unbemannte Drohnen aus, die ferngesteuerte Glasfaserverbindungen so anzapfen, dass dabei keine bemerkbare Störung auftritt.
Auf Online-Jobbörsen verplappern sich ehemalige Angestellte von Geheimdiensten immer wieder.
Kurz nach den SnowdenLeaks kam heraus, dass auf LinkedIn-Profilen die Codenamen dutzender NSA-Programme zu finden waren, teilweise inklusive immer noch geheimer Details. Wer die Anti-Viren-Software des Anbieters Trend Micro installiert hat, hat es Angreifern leicht gemacht, wie der Google-Sicherheitsforscher Travis O'Mandy herausfand. Wenn ihr eine Website mit einem Rechner ansurft, auf dem Trend Micro-Software installiert ist, kann diese Website euren Rechner vollständig übernehmen. Auf diese Weise könnt ihr euch zum Beispiel sogenannte Verschlüsselungs-Druane einfangen. Auch wenn Trend Micro immer wieder unangenehm auffallen, auch andere Hersteller von Sicherheitssoftware stehen immer wieder in der Kritik.
So schalteten zum Beispiel einige Hersteller die Windows Firewall aus, obwohl die Produkt selber keinen vollständigen Schutz bieten konnte.
Was haben wir gelernt? Sich eine Anti-Viren-Software zu installieren macht den Rechner nicht unbedingt sicherer. Das war Emily Ulbricht mit den NerdNews. Vielen Dank.
Radio hat einen Namen.
Das Chaos Radio im Blumen auf Fritz ist schon eine Stunde alt. In einer Stunde haben wir noch und sprechen heute hier mit Leuten vom Chaos Computer Club und aus den mehreren Umfeld über künstliche Intelligenz. Und ich heiße nochmal herzlich willkommen Priska, Klee, Tobias und Dentor. Hallo und guten Abend. Und wir haben in der ersten Stunde geklärt, was KI kann, nämlich Menschen im Go-Spielen schlagen, auch im Schachspielen, das ist schon seit längerem. Das ab und zu so Dinge gibt es Schieflauf mit künstlicher Intelligenz und haben dann versucht zu erklären, was ist das eigentlich und wie macht man das? Und sind dann auf den Begriff neuronale Netze gestoßen. Und ich habe versucht, aus den verehrten Anwesenden eine Erklärung heraus zu pressen. Und ich habe es bis jetzt noch nicht so genau verstanden, weil ich habe was rausgekommen ist, dass neuronale Netze Dinge sind, die man Daten reintut und dann kommen die irgendwie raus und da kommunizieren einzelne Neuronen miteinander. Aber wie das genau funktioniert und das bei dem ganzen Thema KI irgendwie so, das wirkt alles so magisch. Also es gibt immer einen bestimmten Punkt, wo Daten reingeworfen werden und dann fällt ein Ergebnis raus. Und dann sagt Tobias, das sind einfach nur Suchergebnisse. Und ich habe trotzdem nicht genau verstanden, wie es funktioniert. Falls ihr das auch nochmal genau nachfragen wollt, könnt ihr euch gerne anrufen unter 0331 77 97 110. Und ich möchte es wenigstens noch ein einziges Mal probieren. Neuronale Netze, was ist das?
Gut, also ich finde es ganz wichtig, dass wir, bevor wir zu den Netzen kommen, erklären, wie funktioniert so ein einzelnes Neuronen. Ich habe ja vorhin schon gesagt, wir haben diese Eingabevektoren. Die sind grün oder blau, spam oder kein spam. Und der Algorithmus, der ein Perzeptron lernt, das ist so eine ganz geniale, ein Perzeptron ist jetzt so ein einziges Neuron. Dieses Perzeptron besteht im Grunde nur aus einem Vektor, der in eine Richtung zeigt. Also wir stellen uns einen Vektorraum vor und dieses, was ist ein Vektorraum?
Also eine Einzelinformation oder wie?
Nee, es ist ein Raum, in dem Punkte drin sein können, Datenpunkte. Und das Perzeptron zeigt jetzt in dieser, es kann einfach Daten separieren in Gut und Schlecht. Und das tut es, indem es eine Ebene durch diesen Raum legt. Du kannst dir das als ein Blatt Papier vorstellen und auf der linken Seite machst du mit Bleistiftpunkte rein und auf der rechten Seite machst du mit Füllerpunkte rein. Und das Perzeptron, das kann einfach, wenn es weiß, ob die Punkte mit Bleistiften oder Füller gemalt sind, kann es eine Ebene finden, die die Bleistiftpunkte von den Füllerpunkten trennt. Eine Linie.
Okay, also ich versuch's nochmal, ob ich's richtig verstanden habe, das ist auch ein ganz einfaches Beispiel. Ein Einsatzperzeptron kann im Zahlenraum zwischen 1 und 100 arbeiten und kann dann unterscheiden, die Zahl, die ich reingebe, ist über 50 oder unter 50.
Nein, das tut es mit mehrdimensionalen Daten. Das ist das eigentlich Interessante dabei.
Das könnte es tun.
Das war das maximal einfache Beispiel und das ist korrekt gesagt. Also du hast verstanden, was das einfachste Element tut.
Aber das kann man halt im mehrdimensionalen, also auf ein Blatt Papier benutzen, um eben diese Bleistiftpunkte von den Füllerpunkten zu trennen, egal wie sie verteilt sind. Also wenn die Bleistiftpunkte tendenziell eher links oben sind und die Füllerpunkte tendenziell eher rechts unten, dann wird die Ebene halt so schief, dass der Klassifizierungsfehler, wie man so schön sagt, minimiert wird.
Also sage, aber ein einziges Neuron unterscheidet tatsächlich immer hart.
Genau, also die Einschränkung von einem einzelnen Neuron ist, dass es nur diese eine Linie zeichnen kann. Die kann auch keine Kurven mehr machen oder sowas. Und wenn man halt für bestimmte Datensätze dann Kurven braucht, dann muss man neuronale Netze zusammenscheiden aus einzelnen Perzeptronen.
Also das Perzeptronen kann nur hart unterscheiden zwischen Ja und Nein. Und es kann nur eine Ebene, also eine lineare Separierung in die Daten einbringen.
Also das heißt, du sagst, ich gebe da etwas hinein und dann kriege ich von dem einzelnen Neuron die Antwort, okay, das gehört jetzt dazu oder das gehört nicht dazu.
Genau. Und der Lernalgorithmus, das ist das Schöne daran, der ändert diese Ebene nur dann, wenn eine Falschklassifizierung passiert ist. Und deswegen habe ich vorhin auch wieder gesprochen und gesagt, die lernen eigentlich aus negativen Feedback.
Also ich gebe einen Punkt in dieses einzelne Neuron rein, das Neuron sagt Bleistift und ich sage nein, das war Füller.
Ja, dann dreht es die Ebene ein bisschen und vielleicht wird beim nächsten Mal das dann richtig klassifiziert. Und es gibt da so eine Theorie dazu, die sagt, dass wenn die Daten linear separierbar sind, dann findet der Perzeptron Algorithmus eine solche separierende Ebene. Das ist bewiesen und man weiß sogar, wie lange es dauert.
Okay, und das ist ein Neuron. Und jetzt verknüpft man das.
Da lass ich andere sprechen.
Also zum einen nimmt man viele dieser künstlichen Neuronen und legt sie in einer Ebene nebeneinander, damit man viele kleine Separatoren hat. Damit kannst du aber erst mal nur einfache Muster unterscheiden. Also wenn du zum Beispiel ein Bild hast, dann könntest du in einer solchen ersten Ebene von künstlichen Neuronen erkennen, ok, da sind Balken, horizontale, vertikale Balken.
Also wenn ich ein Bild hab, kann man dann Pixel unterteilen? Ist dann quasi ein Neuron ein Pixel? Oder macht ein Neuron eine bestimmte Eigenschaft eines Pixels und ein weiteres Neuron macht eine andere Eigenschaft desselben Pixel?
Tatsächlich ist, ja, ein zweiteres. Und tatsächlich ist jedes Neuron mit allen Eingabepixeln verbunden und kann sich aussuchen, das links unten ist mir vollkommen egal, das rechts oben interessiert mich total.
Das sind die kleinen Drehräder, von denen ich vollgesprach.
Oder die Gewichte. Aber auf dieser ersten Ebene lernst du halt sehr einfache Muster nur. Zum Beispiel eben Balken, orientierte Balken.
Da ist ein Strich in dem Bild.
Da ist ein Strich in dem Bild, genau. Und was wir aber erkennen wollen, sind doch zum Beispiel Gesichter. Und deswegen hat man mehrere Schichten von solchen Naronen übereinander, weil du auf jeder Ebene höher komplexere Muster erkennen kannst. Also wenn du zum Beispiel auf der untersten Ebene Striche erkannt hast, dann kannst du auf einer Ebene drüber Kombinationen von Strichen erkennen. Und so weiter, bis du dann ein Auge erkannt hast und zuletzt ein Gesicht.
Und dieses eine Ebene drüber ist das, man programmiert quasi das einzelne Neuron und programmiert dann Regeln, wie ein Neuron mit anderen Neuronen kommuniziert. Und den Rest lernt das System alleine oder werden diese Ebenen übern...
Also die Architektur ist quasi vorgegeben.
Also Menschen überlegen sich, wie viele Ebenen baue ich auf und wie viele Neurone kommen in jene Ebene. Und die Gewichte lernt das Netz dann aus den Daten.
Okay, jetzt habe ich zumindest eine grobe Idee davon, was ein Neurales Netzwerk sein könnte. Vielen Dank. Wenn man sich jetzt zugehört und dachte so, okay, und das weiter lernen möchte. Eine Antwort ist immer Wikipedia. Ich weiß nicht, wie du sagen, wie gut der Artikel über neuronale Netze da ist, aber habt ihr irgendwie Literaturempfehlungen oder Link-Tipps oder Autoren, wo man sagt, okay, wenn ihr das wissen wollt, geht dahin, die erklären das gut.
Also es gibt, bei Wikipedia hat man oft das Problem, dass es sehr schnell absurd technisch und mathematisch wird. Da kann man Pech haben, wenn man dahin geht. Es gibt einen sehr intuitiven und mit vielen Bildern gemachten Blogartikel. Den findet man, wenn man nach neural networks und Chris Ola, O-L-A-H, googelt. Da findet man diesen Blogartikel.
Wenn ihr diese Sendung als Podcast hört, dann wird der Link auch in den Shownotes auf der Webseite stehen.
Genau. Aber sonst, wenn man nach neural networks Beginner Tutorial sucht und so weiter. Es gibt unglaublich viele Ressourcen dazu, weil das ein sehr stark in Mode gekommenes Thema ist.
Wir haben jetzt so lange nur über das Grundkonzept des neuralen Netzwerks gesprochen. Ist das sozusagen so, dass man sagt, oder die Anlassung gefragt, ein neuronales Netzwerk, ist das momentan gleichbedeutend mit, das ist KI? Wenn man heutzutage von irgendwas spricht, was konzident ist, dann sind es eigentlich immer neuronale Netzwerke?
Also sehr, sehr oft kommen neuronale Netzwerke als eine Komponente vor. So ein neuronales Netz an sich würde ich noch nicht als intelligent bezeichnen. Das kann keine Pläne machen oder sich Aktionen überlegen, die es als nächstes ausführt oder so. Das ist nur eine Komponente. Und es ist auch nicht das einzige Verfahren, was diese Aufgabe lösst. Das ist das aktuell erfolgreiche Verfahren.
Das ist quasi jetzt gerade Mode.
Also wenn wir über das Thema KI reden, dann denke ich als erstes mal an Computer-KIs. Also Computerspieler in Counter-Strike oder irgendwelchen Adventure-Games. Und die arbeiten, die benutzen oft gar keine neuronalen Netze. Oft sind das einfach nur Regeln, das sind einfach nur Skripte, die mit einer bestimmten Wahrscheinlichkeit abgespielt werden. Und deswegen dem Spieler den Eindruck erwecken, es handele sich um ein halbwegs intelligentes System. Weil da gibt es auch ein Feedback, eine Feedback-Funktion, das ist ganz interessant. Also der Computerspieler, der drischt auf dich ein, entweder mit der Hauptwaffe oder mit der Nebenwaffe. Und der zählt, wie oft es erfolgreich war. Und wenn sich also eine Strategie als nicht-erfolgversprechend herausstellt, dann verringert der Computer die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass dieser Angriff erfolgt und er erhöht im Gegenzug die Wahrscheinlichkeit eines andersartigen Angriffes. Das heißt, es ist immer wieder eine Herausforderung für einen Spieler und das wird auch als künstliche Intelligenz wahrgenommen.
Ich finde, von mir nicht. Mir ist das nicht intelligent.
Das wollte ich auch gerade sagen. Computerspiel ist etwas, was ich sehr viel mache. Und da erkennt man sehr schnell die Grenzen, dass es halt genau nicht menschlich wirkt. Gerade wenn du Ego-Shooter sagst, ist der Unterschied, gegen Computergegner zu spielen und gegen Menschen ist halt total extrem.
Aber wenn du eine gut aufgedrehte KI hast, dann kann die viel besser spielen als ein Mensch. Ich weiß nicht, ob einer von euch mal Quake gespielt hat mit dieser Railgun. Da kannst du auf eine irre Entfernung Leute totschießen, weil die keine Dispersion hat. Weil die, wenn du genau genug zielst, einfach trifft. Und so ein Computergegner, der kann halt viel besser zielen als ein Mensch.
Ja, genau.
Also die sind nicht unbedingt schlechter.
Nein, nicht schlechter, aber nicht intelligent, nicht kreativ genau. Also es gibt natürlich Computergegner, die mich sehr leicht besiegen können. Aber das wirkt dann meistens nicht, dass es aus einem kreativen Spiel kommt, sondern das wirkt halt, weil sie die Ebenen sehr gut ausnutzen können.
Das Wesentliche daran ist ja, die können ja nur das. Dieses Ding kann ja dann nur Counter-Strike spielen. Aber die Frage, die hier gestellt wird, ist auch tatsächlich eine, mit der sich Philosophen beschäftigen. Ab wann ist denn ein System als intelligent anzusehen? Und es gibt auch die etwas einfache Definition, dass du ein System dann als intelligent ansehen kannst, wenn es für dich am besten dadurch vorhersehbar ist, dass du es quasi als Mensch betrachtest. Also der Lee Sedol, der gegen AlphaGo gespielt hat, der hat garantiert nicht versucht, einen Computer auszutricksen, sondern er hat es so gespielt, als würde er gegen einen Menschen spielen. Und das hat Daniel Dennett, der Philosoph, mal mit den verschiedenen Herangehensweisen bezeichnet, dass du ein System auf der physikalischen Ebene dir angucken kannst und irgendwann vielleicht noch verstehst, warum irgendwie, indem du den Pfad nachverfolgst, warum aus dieser einen Eingabe die andere Ausgabe gekommen ist. Aber vielleicht fährst du damit für dich selbst viel besser anzunehmen, dass du da einem Menschen gegenüber sitzt, der mit dir jetzt gerade Gruß spielt. Und genau, also diese Frage ist tatsächlich nicht so ganz geklärt. Ab wann bezeichnen wir etwas als künstlich intelligent, ab wann nicht. Und ich finde diesen pragmatischen Ansatz relativ eingängig, dass man sich irgendwie selbst fragt. Zum Beispiel, wenn dein Auto selbst fährt oder sowas, dann kannst du als anderer Verkehrsteilnehmer fährst du am besten damit, dir zu überlegen, da sitzt ein Mensch am Steuer. Oder dir vorzustellen, da sitzt ein Mensch am Steuer. Dann funktioniert das selbstfahrende Auto am besten. Ich glaube, damit hast du total gut erklärt, warum viele Leute diese Systeme so gruselig finden. Weil man nicht genau weiß, als was man es jetzt genau ansehen soll. Man kann es nicht so richtig als Computerprogramm verstehen, weil es teilweise halt Dinge macht, die man ihm nicht explizit gesagt hat. Aber man kann es auch nicht so ganz als Mensch verstehen, weil es sich doch noch irgendwie anders verhält. Und dann ist es irgendwie gruselig, so ein Zwischending. Das steckt da glaube ich mit drin, in der Definition, die du gerade gegeben hast. Sehe ich aus.
Ist es denn so, dass man, also das klingt für mich so, dass zumindest theoretisch, es gibt KI's, die von niemandem mehr sozusagen vorhersagbar durch Blick werden, auch nicht von ihren Erschaffern.
Ich glaube, das kann man so sagen. Also man versteht ziemlich gut, wie diese Verfahren im Allgemeinen funktionieren, die wir jetzt, also zum Beispiel, du hast neuronale Netze erklärt. Man versteht, was das einzelne Neuron da drin macht. Aber nachdem das neuronale Netz dann trainiert ist auf irgendeiner komplizierten Aufgabe, dann löst es diese Aufgabe. Aber man kann nicht mehr genau sagen, was für Schritte es macht, warum es diese Aufgabe jetzt löst. Ob es jetzt die Bilder mit den Panzern so und so sortiert, weil der Panzer sind oder weil die Sonne scheint, man weiß es nicht, auf welchem Weg dann das System die Lösung findet. Also es ist nicht so, dass die Forschung da nicht daran interessiert ist, das besser zu verstehen. Es gibt Leute, die arbeiten an Theorien, wie dieses Lernen funktioniert. Und es gibt auch Leute, die ganz pragmatisch einfach fertige neuronale Netze anschauen und so untersuchen, wie ein Gehirnforscher einen Gehirn untersuchen würde. Die geben also irgendwie Reize rein und untersuchen dann, wie irgendwo tief in dem Netz so ein paar Neuronen darauf reagieren und schauen sich das dann an und machen Schaubilder und so.
Also pragmatisch, Entschuldigung, ganz kurz, pragmatisch nur für dieses Beispiel. Du fütterst ein Bild rein und dann guckst du, welche Muster hat das neuronale Netz denn da drin entdeckt?
Also um die Frage zu beantworten, ja, es ist teilweise mysteriös, was die machen. Nicht, weil wir es nicht im Prinzip verstehen, sondern weil wir es im konkreten Fall, nachdem es auf eine Anwendung trainiert wurde, nicht mehr verstehen.
Also die Ironie, die mich gerade überfällt, ist die, dass ja, ihr habt ja vorhin gesagt, was ja auch sozusagen ein anderer Teil ist, dass es ja ein bisschen daherkommt, dass man versucht, den Menschen nachzubauen, also damit auch den Menschen zu verstehen. Das Einzige, was man geschaffen hat, ist also Maschinen, also Software, aber sozusagen eine Technik, die man jetzt auch nicht mehr versteht. Heißt das, dass Intelligenz letztlich für den Menschen nicht verständlich ist?
Das liegt nur daran, dass das jetzt diese ingenieursmäßig motivierten Verfahren sind. Die wurden halt entwickelt mit dem Ziel, dass man diese Probleme lösen wollte, wie zum Beispiel erkennen, was auf einer Bild ist oder selbst fahren der Autos bauen usw. Das muss noch nicht bedeuten, dass Intelligenz im Prinzip unverstehbar ist. Wir haben jetzt halt nur erst mal Systeme gebaut, die halt irgendwie ein bisschen unübersichtlich sind. Aber vielleicht können wir diese unübersichtlichen Systeme im Laufe der Zeit noch besser verstehen. Es ist ja besser, man hat ein unübersichtliches System, was man dann noch erforschen kann, als man hat gar nichts.
Naja, aber wir hatten ja schon ein unübersichtliches System, was wir erforscht haben, nämlich das menschliche Gehirn.
Ja, aber das kann man nicht auseinandernehmen.
Was ich mich natürlich frage, ist, dass es schwierig ist, das zu erklären, also die Magie, die in der KI passiert. Das liegt natürlich jetzt bei uns ganz konkret an der eingeschränkten Sendungszeit, an den wenigen Formwissen etc. Aber tatsächlich habe ich das Gefühl, in dem ganzen Thema gibt es immer diese Schwelle, wo es uns Magische kippt. Weil ihr auch sagt, im Prinzip haben wir gerade das Thema geschafft. Wir wissen sozusagen, wie das einzelne Neuron, wie es im Grundsatz funktioniert, aber dann wissen wir es irgendwann wieder nicht. Das heißt, wir haben ein weiteres System geschaffen. Jetzt hast du gesagt, na klar, bei dir kann man auseinandernehmen. Das stimmt, aber was macht man damit? Man baut vielleicht ein neues System, aber das wird dann auch wieder zu komplex und so weiter. Das finde ich schon sehr, sehr spannend.
Das kommt aber sehr stark drauf an, was für ein System du hast. Bei neuronalen Netzen ist es jetzt zufällig irgendwie schwieriger. Aber sagen wir, ich habe auch mal mit Agenten gearbeitet, die ein Motivations- und Emotionssystem hatten.
Softwareagenten.
Was sind Softwareagenten? Im Prinzip ein kleines Programm, das in Minecraft rumläuft und da Dinge tut. Das hat bestimmte Bedürfnisse gehabt. Zum Beispiel, dass es sich in angenehmen Temperaturen aufhält. Dann konnte man das beobachten und feststellen, das oscilliert relativ stark hin und her zwischen Wüste und Berggipfel. In diesem Fall konnte man nachgucken und hat festgestellt, es geht in die Wüste, dann wird ihm zu heiß. Dann denkt er sich, wo war ich schon mal, wo es mir nicht zu heiß war? Und geht dann schnell auf den Berggipfel. Das ist ein Fehlverhalten, aber wo du aufgrund des Modells, was verwendet wird, nachgucken konntest, warum hat es sich so verhalten? Es gilt nicht für alle Modelle der KI, dass man nicht in die reingucken könnte und die verstehen.
Es gibt sogar KI-Systeme, die komplett ohne Fasilogik auskommen. Was wir jetzt beschrieben haben, waren so Soft-Activation-Geschichten. Also alles mit viel Statistik und ich mittel irgendwas, und dann bilde ich einen Schwellwert. Es gibt auch Systeme, die direkt auf Regeln arbeiten. Also die versuchen in den Mustern, nicht irgendwelche Gewichte zu erkennen und die dann aufzusummieren, sondern die direkt Regeln ableiten und sagen, ich habe hier eine Regel gefunden, die ist in 95% aller Fälle richtig, also schreibe ich mir die mal raus.
Dass dann sagen, das ist so hart. Also sowas wie, wenn die Ampel rot sind, halte ich halt an. Also wie wir auch manchmal Dinge lernen.
Oder eben, wie gesagt, wenn ich Windeln kaufe, dann kaufe ich auch Bier, weil ich brauch's wahrscheinlich. Und dergleichen mehr. Und mit diesen Regellernern, da gibt es eben dann auch Methoden, also wie man bei den neuronalen Netzen einzelne Neuronen zu Netzwerken kombiniert, kombiniert man auch einzelne Regeln zu Ensembles aus Regeln, die man dann auf bestimmte Weisen miteinander kombiniert und deren Mächtigkeit erhöht. Und der Vorteil von diesem System ist eben, dass man die Regeln im Nachhinein noch lesen kann und was rein interpretieren kann. Das ist für Menschen immer sehr wichtig, dass sie in das, was sie vor sich haben, was rein interpretieren können.
Aber da kann man dann zu jedem Zeitpunkt sagen, das System hat jetzt so und so entschieden, dann kann das System immer sagen, das hab ich aufgrund folgender Regelstruktur gemacht. Dann kann man genau nachschlagen, wie die Entscheidung zustande kam.
Ja, beziehungsweise das Ziel des Lerners ist es sogar, Regeln auszuspucken, die für einen Menschen brauchbar sind. Das gibt es eben auch. Das ist dann das Thema Wissensentdeckung und Data Mining. Da ist also der Nutzen für den Menschen nicht der, dass das System irgendwas tut, sondern dass der Mensch eigene Erkenntnisse, auf die er selber nicht gekommen wäre, mit Hilfe von Computertechniken, mit Hilfe von diesem Suchverfahren, das eben viel schneller rechnen kann, als er suchen kann, generiert.
Gibt es da schon ein Beispiel, was auf diesem Wege rausgefunden wurde?
Ja, die Recommender Systems sind eigentlich das berühmteste Beispiel. Also Kunden, die diesen Artikel gekauft haben, interessierten sich auch für diesen Artikel. Und damit optimieren halt Warenhausketten ihren Umsatz. Also das, was ich erzählt habe vorhin mit dem Walmart und dem Bier, das hat tatsächlich eine Konsequenz gehabt. Und zwar hat Walmart dann das Bier neben die Windeln gestellt und die Bierverkäufe gingen hoch.
Das ist ja auch ein schönes Beispiel. Also gerade dieses Recomender-System, also quasi Kunden, die kaufen, kaufen. Also die Windeln kaufen, kaufen auch Bier. Ich kenne ja anekdotisch zumindest das so. Das funktioniert eher nicht. Also gerade wenn man sozusagen bei Amazon, wo das ja sozusagen am bekanntesten ist, guckt, das ist der, wenn er im Prinzip, wenn er, die letzte Sache, die ich mir angeguckt habe, muss ich, da zieht sich dann durch meine gesamte Empfehlungsliste, aber eigentlich ist nichts drin, was mich interessiert. Warum geht das so schnell schief?
Du hast zu wenig gekauft bei Amazon.
Ich wünschte, du hättest recht, aber das ist nicht der Fall.
Jemand anders benutzt dein Account nicht?
Nein. Also ist es sozusagen für die egal? Oder anders gefragt? Die empfehlen mir Kram, wo ich denke, das ist totaler Quatsch. Ist deren System zu billig oder ist das egal? Oder ist das irgendeine Logik, die ich nicht verstehe und die funktioniert bei allen anderen Leuten außer bei mir?
Vielleicht ist das der Punkt. Vielleicht haben alle anderen Leute diesen komischen Geschmack und kaufen den Kram.
Ich stelle die ganze Zeit noch auf unsere Sendungsvorbereitung und sehe da noch drei Schlagwörter, wo ich gerne fragen würde. Weil wir haben ja diese ganze Zeit drüber geredet. Also die lernen das irgendwie. Und jetzt gibt es anscheinend noch verschiedene Arten, wie man lernen kann. Hier steht Transferlernen, One-Shot-Lernen und aktives Lernen. Weil ich dachte, wenn Software lernt, gibt es halt dieses eine System, aber scheinbar gibt es verschiedene. Was ist da der Unterschied?
Das sind alles Sachen, die heute noch nicht so richtig gut funktionieren. Das sind also Einschränkungen von den aktuellen Systemen. Also, wenn man die Frage stellt, was können diese Systeme denn jetzt heute noch nicht? Also, sie können jetzt Go spielen, aber was trennt die noch von einem Menschen oder so? Dann ist eine Sache zum Beispiel Transferlernen. Das bedeutet, das System wird... Ach, was Quatsch. System, ich kann ja selber Transfer lernen. Ich hab in der Schule Wörter gelernt, mit denen ich Dinge ausdrücken kann. Und später kann ich die gleichen Wörter benutzen, um völlig andere Sachen damit zu machen. Das war gerade schlecht erklärt. Aber Transferlernen, das ist eigentlich eine total intuitive Sache. Also, dass du halt nicht nur eine Sache machen kannst, sondern dass du Teile von dem, was du früher mal gelernt hast, wieder verwenden kannst bei der nächsten Aufgabe. Sodass du bei der nächsten Aufgabe nicht wieder von vorne anfangen musst und von vorne lernen musst, wo oben und unten ist und was ist eigentlich hell und dunkel. Und ich hab zwei Arme. Sondern du kannst viel von dem, was du über die Welt weißt, immer mitnehmen für deine verschiedenen Aufgaben, die du machst. Und die Systeme, die es heute gibt, die sind relativ schlechter drin. Die werden trainiert auf eine bestimmte Aufgabe und dann machen sie halt diese Aufgabe. Und wenn du eine andere Aufgabe hast, kannst du zwar ein System vom gleichen Typ auf die andere Aufgabe trainieren. Und das ist dann auch toll, dass dieses System das selber herausfindet, wie es das macht. Aber du fängst jedes Mal von vorne an. Du fängst quasi immer mit einer Baby-AI an. Und man hätte eigentlich gerne, dass man den Trainingserfolg übertragen kann auf die nächste Aufgabe. Das ist also ein aktives Forschungsfeld.
Das ist Transferlernen? Was ist One-Shot-Learning?
Das ist quasi extremes Transferlernen.
Extrem Transferlernen?
Du hast als Mensch die Fähigkeit, dass ich dir ein Beispiel von der Sache sage. Ich zeige auf irgendein Tier, was da vorne steht. Es hat halt irgendwie komische Hörner oder so. Und dann kannst du mir weitere Beispiele davon zeigen. Das heißt, ich zeige dir ein Beispiel und du verstehst gleich, was die ganze Kategorie ist. Viele aktuelle AI-Systeme sind so, dass sie tausende Beispiele brauchen, bis sie verschiedene Kategorien von Dingen voneinander entscheiden können.
Das ist wie ein Panzerbeispiel. Man muss ganz viele Beispiele reingeben und muss auch noch dafür sorgen, dass sie richtig verstanden werden. Es gibt nicht mal einen, der sagt, hier, das ist ein Fuchs, und dann weiß das System sofort.
Genau, also eigentlich ist die Aufgabe unfair gewesen, die mit den Panzern. Weil wenn man einem Mensch Bilder von Panzern gibt, dann hat er vorher schon ganz viele Bilder gesehen von Wäldern bei Sonnenscheinen, von Wäldern bei bewölktem Himmel, von Wäldern in der Nacht. Und dieser Fundus an Wissen, den ein Mensch im Laufe seines Lebens ansammelt, den hat eine künstliche Intelligenz natürlich nicht, in dem Moment, wo du sie das erste Mal programmierst.
Ist das ein Speicherplatzproblem oder ist das ein Problem, dass die Algorithmen noch nicht so weit sind, dass diese Verarbeitung, dieses Transferlernen sozusagen stattfinden kann?
Na es gibt das Problem, dass einer künstlichen Intelligenz fehlt das Weltwissen und es gibt auch tatsächlich den Ansatz, dass man sich einen kleinen, babyförmigen Roboter baut, den man erstmal wie ein Baby behandelt, damit er wie ein Baby lernen kann, wie die Welt aussieht und wie das Dinge runterfallen, wenn man sie loslässt und dergleichen Dinge und wie ein Wald aussieht und sowas. Und es ist tatsächlich, ich weiß nicht, ob das nach wie vor aktuell ist, aber das war damals in dem Feld die Herangehensweise, wie man so eine AI anlernen kann, dass sie dieses einmal transferfähiges Wissen aufbaut einerseits und andererseits Stimuli, also Bilder oder sowas, in den richtigen Kontext einordnen kann, weil sie halt nun schon mal ein Wald gesehen hat. Das heißt, die Überlegung war halt, man weiß ja noch nicht, ob das stimmt, dass man tatsächlich ein Kind erziehen muss, wo eine künstliche Intelligenz rausguckt, damit es dann wirklich intelligent werden kann.
Das klingt auch wieder sehr gruselig. Also das finde ich tatsächlich sehr spannend, dass man die, also Fazit für mich bis jetzt zu sagen, man kann Intelligenz sozusagen anscheinend, zumindest derzeitiger Stand, nicht einfach bauen, sondern man ist tatsächlich irgendwie darauf angewiesen, man baut komplexe Systeme und die müssen dann aber auch lernen, weil man so ganz genau wie man sozusagen, wie man so ein Weltbild zum Beispiel instantan vorfertigt irgendwo reingeben sagt, okay, da ist es. Das scheint immer noch nicht zu funktionieren. Ich finde es sehr spannend. Wir werden gleich in der letzten halben Stunde nochmal darüber reden, nachdem wir die Grundlagen gelegt haben, was so der Ausblick ist, wann Moderatoren überflüssig werden, weil sie von einer KI ersetzt werden und noch viele andere Dinge. Vorher aber noch die Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr.
Am 2. und 3. September die Fritz-Deutsch-Poeten. Wieder live im Ifa Sommergarten der Messe Berlin. So lange es noch Karten gibt, gibt es Karten im Kombi-Ticket für beide Tage oder einzeln für Freitag oder Samstag. Mehr dazu fritz.de slash deutsch-poeten. Die Fritz-Deutsch-Poeten. Wenn mal wieder Sommer ist.
Mit Emily Ulbricht. Der Terror-Verdächtige Abdislam kann von Belgien nach Frankreich ausgeliefert werden.
Das hat ein Untersuchungsgericht in Brüssel entschieden.
Der 26-jährige Franzose war vor knapp zwei Wochen in der belgischen Hauptstadt verhaftet worden. Er soll bei den Terroranschlägen von Paris im November geholfen haben und war vier Monate lang auf der Flucht.
Bei den Attentaten wurden 130 Menschen getötet.
Abdislams Anwalt sagte, dass sein Mandant mit der Auslieferung einverstanden ist und mit den französischen Behörden zusammenarbeiten will. Der Flughafen in Brüssel kann nach den Anschlägen vor anderthalb Wochen wieder öffnen. Der Betreiber teilte mit, dass die ersten Passagiermaschinen übermorgen starten und landen sollen. Das müssten die Behörden aber noch genehmigen.
Am Brüsseler Flughafen hatten sich vergangene Woche zwei Selbstmordattentäter in die Luft gesprengt. Dabei wurde die Abflughalle stark beschädigt.
Außerdem gab es einen Anschlag auf eine U-Bahn. Insgesamt kamen 32 Menschen ums Leben. Am Montag sollen die ersten 500 Flüchtlinge von Griechenland in die Türkei zurückgeschickt werden.
Das sagten Mitarbeiter der EU-Kommission in Brüssel.
Damit würde die umstrittene Flüchtlingspakt mit der Türkei wie geplant umgesetzt werden.
Demnach sollen alle Flüchtlinge, die seit dem 20.
März in Griechenland angekommen sind, in die Türkei abgeschoben werden. Das Land bekommt dafür mehrere Milliarden Euro.
Außerdem sollen Flüchtlinge aus Lagern in der Türkei legal in die EU übersiedeln können.
Schwere Menschenrechtsverletzungen im WM-Land Katar. Dazu hat Amnesty International der FIFA noch mal schwere Vorwürfe gemacht. In einem Bericht der Menschenrechtsorganisation heißt es, Tausende Arbeiter würden auf den Baustellen ausgebeutet. In einigen Fällen könne man sogar von Zwangsarbeit sprechen. Amnesty wirft dem Fußball-Weltverband vor, zu wenig dagegen zu tun. Die FIFA reagierte zurückhaltend und erklärte, man wisse zwar von den Zuständen auf den Baustellen, vertraue Katar aber. Das Wetter Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Triebduo sind 6 Grad und in Spanau 8 Grad. Grünow und Neuruppinen melden 6 Grad, in Ludwigsfelde und Frankfurt Oder sind 7 Grad.
In der Nacht bleibt es bewölkt und im Süden von Brandenburg regnet es.
Die Temperaturen gehen dann auf 5 bis 2 Grad runter. Der Tag morgen wird netter als heute. Morgens kann es noch etwas regnen. Danach ist es aber überall sonnig und trocken bei maximal 13 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin, Mitte in der Köpenicker Straße zwischen Engeldamm und Michael-Kirch-Straße. Gibt es einen Feuerwehreinsatz, da ist die Straße in beiden Richtungen gesperrt. Und nach Brandenburg?
Vorsicht im kreismärkisch Oderland auf der B168 zwischen Waldsieversdorf und Münchenberg.
Gibt es Gefahr durch eine Herde Pferde auf der Straße? Fahrt hier also bitte besonders vorsichtig. Vorsicht auch auf der L40-Nutestraße Starnsdorf Richtung Potsdam. In der Ausfahrt Horstweg ist die POP-Feuerwehr im Einsatz. Und noch zwei Meldungen zur S-Bahn Berlin. Auf der Linie S2 fahren zwischen Blankenburg und Bernau von 22 Uhr bis Betriebsschluss Busse statt Bahn. Und nach einem Polizeieinsatz in Köpenick fahren die Bahnen auf der Linie S3 zu spät oder fallen ganz aus.
Davo's geht, euch ne gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr am Sonntagnachmittag zocken und lachen wollt, dann macht das doch bei den Sonntags Fritzen mit Kathrin Thüring und Jakob Lund und mit mir, dem Stimulator.
Immer sonntags ab 14 Uhr auf Fritz.
Genauer gesagt Chaos Radio im Blue Moon heute und wir sprechen heute über künstliche Intelligenz, aber das noch mit echten Menschen, nämlich mit Bento, Tobias, Clee und Priska. Hallo nochmal. Und wir haben also erst erklärt, was die Erfolgsmeldungen waren, was schon ganz schön schief gelaufen ist und haben grob versucht zu erklären, wie das überhaupt funktioniert, so eine künstliche Intelligenz. Und wir jetzt ganz zum Schluss noch ein bisschen reden, wo wollen wir denn damit eigentlich hin? Was wird denn noch? Und ich habe also das Klischee, dass man sagt, ja, künstliche Intelligenz, die können ja noch gar nicht so richtig viel. Ich habe jetzt neulich gelesen, eine KI hat den Geschichtenwettbewerb, also nicht gewonnen, ist da aber irgendwie in die Jury, in der Jury vorbeigekommen. Habt ihr das mitbekommen?
Also ich habe das mitbekommen und was da passiert ist, ist, dass die Wissenschaftler haben selbst einen Roman verfasst und die KI hat dann diesen fertigen Roman genommen und hinterher die einzelnen Paragraphen zusammengewürfelt. Und das ist tatsächlich, das klingt wenig beeindruckend und ist für mein Verständnis auch wenig beeindruckend. Es ist einfach nur so, wir waren die ersten, wir haben da irgendwie mal was mit KI gemacht und so, aber es ist tatsächlich nicht wirklich so anspruchsvoll und das kannst du halt auch mit einfachen, das kann halt irgendwie dein 15-jähriger, der ein bisschen PHP fahren kann, sowas auch bauen.
Also sie haben sozusagen einfach Textbausteine sozusagen dann willkürlich aneinander gereitet.
Nach meinem Verständnis ist genau das so passiert.
Das heißt sozusagen, das ist eher ein Armutszeugnis für die Jury oder die Textbausteine waren so belanglos, vielleicht war es auch Dadaismus. Okay, na gut. Ich muss natürlich jetzt fragen, gibt es also Maschinizierung hat ja damals irgendwie viele Jobs ersetzt, jetzt sagt man KI. Der Chatbot von Microsoft war Anfang dem Thema. Wird es irgendwann Radiomoderatoren geben, die KI sind?
Also wir können halt an der Stelle schwer über einen Ausblick reden, ohne kurz zu erwähnen, was denn dieser Touring-Test ist, von dem irgendwie viele Leute schon mal gehört haben können. Und zwar ist das ein hypothetischer, also ist das ein Test, den der Alan Touring damals vor ewig langen Zeiten mal vorgeschlagen hat, um rauszufinden, ob ein Computerprogramm wirklich intelligent ist. Und zwar ist das Setup, dass man eine Art Chat einrichtet, dass es entweder in einem getrennten Raum entweder ein Mensch an der Tastatur oder es ist ein Computerprogramm, was mit dem Prüfer in einem anderen Raum dann chattet. Und das ist eine nach wie vor bestehende Herausforderung für die Programmierung von künstlichen Intelligenzen. Da gibt es auch Leute, die da aktiv dran arbeiten, das endlich mal zu gewinnen. Diese Challenge mit einer natürlich programmierten künstlichen Intelligenz, die dann sich tatsächlich verkaufen kann als tatsächliche 16-Jährige oder sowas, wie halt da jetzt mit Tay so ansatzweise passieren sollte. Und da sind wir noch nicht. Also ich glaube, letztes Jahr hat irgendwie gerade mal die Runde gemacht, dass ein Programm, was vorgab, ein nicht englischer, also kein natürlicher Muttersprachler zu sein. Und ein 15-jähriger Junge in der Ukraine hat halt irgendwie drei von, was waren das, fünf Richter innerhalb von fünf Minuten überzeugt, dass es eventuell eine KI ist. Und das Chat-Log, wenn man sich das anguckt, da fragt man sich, was haben die denn geraucht? Das ist doch nie im Leben.
Wie war das? Ein Mensch?
Drei von fünf Menschen haben dieses Programm als, haben gesagt, da sitzt ein Junge auf der anderen Seite. Und da ist ein Programm da, was einfach nur durch schlechtes Englisch und vorgeschobenen geringem Alter diesen drei Leuten vorgegaukelt hat.
Mit anderen Worten, wenn du keine Interaktion zulässt, könnte man dich vielleicht ersetzen durch ein Chatbot mit richtiger Interaktion mit prüfenden Menschen. Also ist es erstmal noch schwierig.
Puh, sehr schön. Dann kann ich da noch eine Weile hier arbeiten. Das finde ich ja ganz beruhigend.
Allerdings gibt es schon Zeitungsartikel zu bestimmen, normalerweise Domainspezifisch, die von Programmen geschrieben werden, zum Beispiel Sportnuss.
Das kann ich mir natürlich vorstellen. Das lustige, da kommen wir jetzt zu Computerspielen. Bei den Fußballspielen wird ja immer sozusagen, das Einkwalitätsteam, immer sozusagen, wie gut sind die Kommentatoren, die in dem Fußballspiel eingebaut sind? Und da merkt man halt noch sehr deutlich diese Floskelwolken, die da sozusagen angegeben werden für bestimmte Spielereignisse. Man kann die schon erkennen. Aber wenn man sich dann ein richtiges Fußballspiel anhört, denkt man so, so groß ist der Unterschied eigentlich nicht mehr. Also gerade weil Sportkommentatoren ja auch dazu tendieren, immer wieder dieselben Sachen zu sagen. Okay.
Also eigentlich muss man ja, um ein Fußballspiel zu kommentieren, einfach immer nur den, den der Ball hat, bei Namen nennen. Und wenn der Ball in die Nähe vom Tor kommt, die Stimme heben.
Ich glaube, es ist ein bisschen komplizierter, aber vielleicht.
Ich hab keine Ahnung von Fußballspiel.
Wo will man denn noch hin mit der KI? Also was sind denn jetzt sozusagen Sachen, die man tatsächlich noch machen will?
Also es gibt halt, es gibt natürlich starkes wirtschaftliches Interesse, im Prinzip alles zu automatisieren, wo man heute in Menschen bezahlen muss. Also für jeden Job findest du irgendwo jemanden, der gerne hätte, dass er da eine AI hat, die diesen Job stattdessen macht. Und es gibt einige Aufgabenfelder, wo das halt durchaus realistisch ist, dass das irgendwann in den nächsten 20, 30 Jahren oder so tatsächlich passieren kann. Auch wenn es dann keine KI ist, die mit uns redet und eine Persönlichkeit hat oder so. Aber die kann ja vielleicht trotzdem Akten wälzen und ein Gerichtsprozess ein bisschen vorbereiten, helfen oder so. Das heißt, was man schon so ein bisschen erwarten kann, ist, dass halt die Arbeitswelt sich stark ändert. Es gibt eine Studie, was natürlich Kaffeesatzleserei ist, aber es ist eine Studie von zwei Oxford-Professoren, die zu dem Thema forschen und die haben am Ende die Zahl rausgekriegt, dass 47 Prozent der Jobs in den Vereinigten Staaten absehbar, also kann noch eine Weile dauern, Jahrzehnte, aber absehbar von Automatisierung betroffen sein könnten. Steht in unserem Text-Dingsbuch.
Kann man klar sagen, das sind Jobs, die bestimmte Dinge erfordern? Oder ist das einfach die Hälfte aller Jobs wird ersetzt?
Das naheliegende Beispiel, was vielleicht auch schon diverse Leute mitbekommen haben, sind ja die selbstfahrenden Autos, die in absehbarer Zeit, wenn da nicht ganz krasse rechtliche Hütten noch aufgebaut werden, die Fernfahrer ersetzen können werden. Und nicht nur die. Genau, und nicht nur die, das ist jetzt auch schon absehbar. Und diverse Science-Fiction Autoren malen auch jetzt schon die Szenarien an die Wand, dass diejenigen, die dann noch darauf bestehen, ihr Auto selbst zu steuern, ganz krass hohe Versicherungspolizen bezahlen müssen. Und sonst werden sie nicht mehr selbst an Steuer gelassen. Weil es ist auch heute schon so, so statistisch gesehen, sind die selbstfahrenden Autos weitaus weniger unfallanfällig als der Durchschnittsautofahrer. Und es wird einen starken politischen Willen auch in die Richtung geben. Also es gibt da verschiedene Strömungen. Die einen wollen die Fernfahrer nicht abschaffen und die anderen sagen, aber die Straßen wären so viel sicherer, wenn wir das tun würden.
Wie ist es denn eigentlich, es gibt ja im Science-Film auch das Klischee oder diese Vision des persönlichen Assistenten, der im Prinzip nur ein Computerprogramm ist. Wie weit sind wir davon entfernt? Ist das überhaupt etwas, wo man KI braucht oder will und wird daran gearbeitet?
Also wenn ich mir meinen Siri und mein Sprachdialogsystem von der Navi angucke, dann sage ich, wir sind da noch nicht sehr weit.
Das würde ich genau auch so sagen. Aber die Frage ist sozusagen, wird das kommen oder ist das eh illusorisch als Anwendung?
Also ich würde dem ein bisschen widersprechen. Ich finde das Ganze, also ich finde gerade Siri beeindruckender, als ich jetzt erwartet hätte. Also als jemand, der sich mit dem Thema auskennt. Ich habe damals im Studium selbst mal versucht, Spracherkennung und ähnliche Dinge zu machen. Und das, was dann halt irgendwie auf den Tisch geworfen wurde von den diversen Herstellern, das fand ich persönlich relativ beeindruckend. Aber ich sehe natürlich auch, dass da jetzt noch ein großes Potenzial herrscht. Da ist definitiv Verbesserungspotenzial drin. Aber dass du irgendwann, also auch in absehbarer Zeit, in natürlicher Sprache dein Computer sagen wirst können, so mach mal einen Termin für morgen und so. Keine Ahnung, Kleintreffen oder so.
Aber das ist witzig, da sind wir wieder an dem Punkt, wo ich sagen würde, das ist für mich nicht künstliche Intelligenz. Also weil, also jetzt in meinem persönlicher Leben ist es so klar, ich kann in das Telefon was sagen und das wird in Text übersetzt und dann reagiert es auf eine Art und Weise, wo ich sehr genau sehen kann, ok, du hast jetzt einen Stichpunkt da rausgenommen und das war's dann. Und davon abstrahiert, ich habe ein Programm, wo ich sozusagen Freitext eintragen kann, irgendwie treffen mit CCC am 7.3. und der organisiert aus diesem Halbsatz in der Hinschreibe einen Kalendereintrag. Das ist aber für mich nicht KI, sondern der Assistent ist halt eher so ein Ding, eigentlich müsste ich mal vielleicht irgendwie dennächst wieder mal im Club vorbeischauen und dann sagt er so, naja, irgendwie vielleicht gehst du nächsten Donnerstag hin, da ist irgendwie auch diese Veranstaltung und das passt doch in deinen Zeitplan.
Also Leute, die diese Veranstaltung besucht haben, könnten sie auf die folgende Podcastshow besuchen, interessieren. Also die Bildung Blocks haben wir, wir haben die Spracherkennung, wir haben die Recommender Systems. Eigentlich haben wir das alles, aber im Endeffekt funktioniert es nicht anständig.
Es wird aber ganz klar aktiv daran geforscht und wahrscheinlich ist es auch noch viel stärker im Einsatz in gerade in so Ländern wie Japan, wo die Scheu mit KI's zu interagieren viel geringer ist als hier in Europa.
Ja, also ich komm ja selbst blöd vor, wenn ich in mein Handy reinrede und da ist niemand, der mir da gerade zuhört. Und ich muss ja, das ist ja auch der Trick mit Siri gewesen, das ist ja absichtlich vermenschlicht, sodass ich mich dann traue mit meinem Handy zu reden, um meinem Handy zu sagen, so hier, find doch mal raus, was morgen für ein Wetter ist. Und es, gerade in Japan, Japan hat noch andere Features, also Japanisches sehr leicht zu parsen, also sehr leicht für einen Computer in einzelne Bausteine zu übersetzen, den man dann mehr Bedeutung entziehen kann als jetzt zum Beispiel Deutsch. Aber das nur so am Rande. Und für mich, ich hab mich halt damals in meinem Studium viel mit diesem ganzen simplen Problem beschäftigt, wie kann man Sprache erkennen? Das kannst du halt auch nicht runterprogrammieren, das musst du auch erlernen, das musst du den Computer erlernen lassen. Und gerade da sehe ich, dass auf jeden Fall so kommen, dass ganz krasse Fortschritte gemacht werden.
Du hast es gerade bei den autonomen Autos schon gesagt, naja, wenn da nicht irgendwie noch rechtliche Hürden kommen. Eine spannende Frage bei KI ist tatsächlich auch, also beim Auto gibt es ja dieses Klischeebeispiel, was, wenn das autonome Auto etwas überfährt. Aber generell ist es ja so, wie wird denn es eigentlich mit der Verantwortung? Also sagen, Dinge, die eine KI tut oder entscheidet, wer hat denn da die Verantwortung für?
Im Moment natürlich der Fahrer. Also wenn wir von diesem Teilautom, von diesem hochpilotierten Fahren sprechen, dann ist es natürlich der Fahrer. Da gibt es einen Disclaimer. Aber prinzipiell, wenn Autos vollautomatisch unterwegs sind, hat der Hersteller die Verantwortung.
Ich meine, sagen nicht nur auf Autos beschränkt, sondern generell, wenn man sich das vorstellt, sagen Dinge, also KI, wir nehmen 50% unserer Jobs, sondern in diesem Job läuft was schief.
Also wäre es dann daran schuld, dass ich keinen Job mehr hab, oder?
Nein, nein, wer ist daran schuld, wenn in diesem Job was schief läuft? Ist es der Programmierer?
Fragst du nach dem Status Quo oder?
Ich frage beides, also tatsächlich nach dem zu sagen, wie ist das jetzt gerade, also bei Autos ist das der Hersteller, aber auch, was für Ideen gibt es, wie man damit umgeht in Zukunft? Also werden KI's irgendwann juristische Personen?
Man begibt hier ja wieder so ein bisschen den menschlichen Fehler, also man begeht den menschlichen Fehler, dass einzelne Missgeschicke unbedingt einen Schuldigen haben müssen. So sind wir Menschen halt nun mal verdrahtet. Wir wollen halt irgendwie gerne Finger zeigen. Aber wenn man halt auf der anderen Seite hingeht und sagt, das ist halt einfach nur ein dummer Unfall, dann müsste man jetzt irgendwie mit leben. Wir müssen jetzt einfach runterkommen von dieser ganzen Wer hat hier fahrlässig gehandelt? Einfach so sagen, ok, dieses Unglück ist einfach nur als Resultat von unglücklichen Begleitumständen entstanden. Und dann müsste man es einfach abhaken und gut ist. So ein bisschen wie wir zum Beispiel Unwetter behandeln. Unwetter, da können wir halt tatsächlich nichts dran machen. Wir können keinen Finger mehr zeigen.
Das ist aber schwierig, weil du sagen würdest, da müsstest du ja vorher eine Gesellschaft geformt haben, wo Unglücke halt passieren können und wo es niemanden doll weh tut.
Oder wo du eine Versicherung hast gegen KI.
Da haben wir glaube ich auch unterschiedliche Meinungen.
Genau, das ist vielleicht auch ein Thema für deinen Rechtspodcast. Sich das ganze Thema da mal aufzurollen. Ich glaube, wir kommen hier heute nicht auf einen gemeinsamen Nenner, was das anbelangt.
Da ist es aber eigentlich doch völlig klar. Also wenn ich ein Produkt kaufe und der Hersteller sagt, das kann automatisch fahren und dann fährt das gegen eine Wand, dann gibt es das Produkthaftungsgesetz. Also die Verantwortlichkeiten da sind eindeutig geregelt. Und in Amerika ist es auch gar kein Problem. Da finden sich dann Versicherungsgesellschaften, die kalkulieren halt einfach das Risiko und berechnen ihre Prämien darauf. In Europa ist das noch nicht möglich, weil es hier die Wiener Konvention gibt, die einfach vorschreibt, dass ein Fahrzeugführer zu jedem Zeitpunkt für sein Fahrzeug verantwortlich ist. Er muss es auch übersteuern können. Da werden die Hersteller dazu verpflichtet. Und darum entwickeln sich die, das pilotierte Fahren entwickelt sich in Deutschland sehr viel langsamer als in Amerika aus genau diesem Grund. Ich persönlich würde sagen, da steckt ein Unterschied in der Philosophie dahinter. Und eventuell haben wir natürlich auch das Interesse, dass unser Logistikmarkt, der sehr personalintensiv ist im Moment, dass wir den nicht komplett entvölkern wollen, weil wir dann wieder ein gesellschaftliches Problem mehr hätten. Wir hätten sehr viele arbeitslose Fernfahrer, Taxifahrer. Die ganze Intensivmedizin könnte man um 10 Prozent, 15 Prozent zurückfahren. Und da stünden ganz viele Leute auf der Straße.
Du meinst, es war jetzt weniger Verkehrstote?
Vor allem weniger Schwerverletzte. Man muss ja sagen, die Verkehrstotenzahlen sind in den letzten 10, 15 Jahren, glaube ich, um die Hälfte gesunken. Von 8.000 in Deutschland auf 4.000 pro Jahr. Groberichtzahlen. Es gibt inzwischen mehr Selbstmorde als es Verkehrstote gibt. Aber der niedrigen Zahl an Verkehrstoten steht eben noch eine sehr hohe Zahl an Schwerverletzten gegenüber. Der Punkt ist einfach der, die Menschen, die sterben, nicht mehr am Unfallort, weil wir eine sehr gut funktionierende Intensivmedizin haben, weil wir ein gutes Netz an Rettungsdiensten haben. Und wenn man einen Menschen innerhalb von 10 Minuten auf die Intensivstation bringt, dann kann der schon fast gar nicht mehr sterben. Also so viel Blut kann man gar nicht verlieren. Und selbst wenn man 10 Minuten lang Hirntod war, kriegt man den Typen irgendwie wieder fit. Und dann bleiben halt Pflegefälle zurück. Und das sind zehnmal mehr als es Verkehrstote gibt. Also da gibt es unter der Oberfläche schon noch einen größeren Teil des Eisbergs. Die volkswirtschaftlichen Kosten der Automobilität sind sehr hoch.
Aber was du sagen möchtest, es ist moralisch auf jeden Fall geboten, dass wir selbstfahrende Autos haben, weil das so viel sicherer ist, selbst wenn es ab und zu mal schief geht. Ich stehe mir dem auch zu.
Okay, dann sagen wir, dass beim selbstfahrenden Autos, bei den persönlichen Assistenten, wissen wir nicht so genau. Ich würde zum Schluss von euch persönlich noch wissen, was für euch jetzt gerade in dem Thema für euch aktuell wird, womit ihr euch vielleicht selber beschäftigt. Oder ob ihr vielleicht selber sozusagen kleine KI's für euch baut, die in eurem Alltag was machen. Vielleicht können wir bei Bento anfangen. KI sozusagen jetzt ganz aktuell bei dir, was wird da in Zukunft eine Rolle spielen? Oder was findest du gerade spannend?
Also ich finde gerade spannend, mir ist vor kurzem die Idee gekommen, dass man zum Beispiel E-Mails nicht unbedingt in Spam und Nicht-Spam klassifizieren braucht. Also nicht ausschließlich, sondern dass man genau den gleichen Ansatz auch für zum Beispiel Themenbereiche verwenden kann. Dass meine E-Mails dann automatisch sortiert werden in Dinge, die ja mit dem CCC zu tun und Dinge, die haben mit der Uni zu tun und derartige Dinge.
Also das...
Letzte Woche habe ich genau über sowas.
Wir müssen uns mal zusammensetzen. Du willst halt nicht selber diese Filter schreiben, sondern du willst, dass ein System lernt, wie die...
Genau. Ich klick dann sozusagen meine Mail und sag halt so, okay, das hier war jetzt Uni und bitte lernen jetzt mal, dass das... Merkt ihr mal, dass eine E-Mail, die so aussieht, kommt von der Uni und ist für Uni relevant und eine E-Mail, die so aussieht, ist irgendwie für Hobby relevant. Und die Erwartung ist ja, weil halt Spam-Filter heutzutage vergleichsweise gut funktionieren, ist, dass die sich auch anwenden lassen auf diesen Themenbereich.
Okay, und du willst nicht nur, dass das thematisch anso tät wird, sondern vielleicht auch so eine Wichtigkeit? Diese Mails solltest du jetzt lesen, die anderen können warten.
Da gibst du mir eine schöne Idee, dass es dann ein zukünftiges...
Falls du das gelöst hast, bitte Bescheid sagen. Ich hätte das auch gern. Tobias?
Ich habe im Moment keine eigenen Projekte. Ich hatte mal eins. Da ging es um die Extraktion von Webseiten-Inhalten. Da habe ich so einen Regel-Lerner gebastelt. Ich mache da aber nicht dran weiter, weil man hat ja immer dieses Rechte-Problem. Sobald du irgendwo aus einer Webseite die Daten rausziehst, kommen die Verlage und verklagen dich.
Aber was findest du spannend beim Thema Chaos? Also gibt es irgendwas, was du jetzt beobachtest?
Ja, also ich finde einfach dieses Thema, dass man Regeln lernen kann, die für Menschen wiederum interpretierbar sind. Und da doch eine, ja, eine gute Statistik dahinter steckt. Das finde ich, ist ein sehr mächtiges Verfahren. Ist ein sehr mächtiger Ansatz. Man kann damit viel machen. Aber ich habe im Moment konkret keine, keine Projekte in der Richtung laufen.
Also ich versuche gerade da hinzukommen, dass ich dran forschen kann, was diese neuronalen Netze innen drin machen. Also ich interessiere mich dafür, wie die funktionieren und wie die Aktivierungen da drin so aussehen und wie man die dazu bringen kann, dass sie verständlich sind. Und möchte auf jeden Fall schauen, dass ich zu den Leuten gehöre, die da dran mit basteln und die wissen, wie das funktioniert und das vielleicht auch irgendwie verständlich halten können oder so. Also die Vision, dass wir total mächtige KI's haben und niemand versteht sie, die finde ich selber auch ein bisschen gruselig. Also ich verwende meinen Spamfilter zu Hause nicht, weil ich dem nicht über den Weg traue. Priska?
Also an Projekten habe ich so mehrere kleine, die mal nebenherlaufen. Primär auch um sich mit Technologie bekannt zu machen. Eins ist zum Beispiel einen kleinen Chatbot zu trainieren, der Tweets im Stil eines Freundes von mir ausspuckt. Ein anderes, was jetzt gerade auch durch AlphaGo wieder aktuell geworden ist, ist halt mal zu gucken, ob man selber nicht so ein Go-Programm trainieren kann. Und weil ich selber Go spiele, ist das umso interessanter, weil ich dann natürlich dagegen spielen möchte. Also da gibt es immer wieder so kleine Projekte nebenher.
Alles klar. Dann vielen Dank, dass ich heute die Zeit genommen habe, um heute versucht, mir und uns zu erklären, was Künstliche Intelligenz ist, wie es funktioniert, wie man es vielleicht lernen kann. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, das war das Chaos Radio. Jetzt hab ich die Nummer vergessen. Verdammt, ich wollte sie mit noch... 221, stimmt, 221. Das nächste Chaos Radio findet ihr nicht bei Fritzstadt, sondern direkt beim Chaos Computer Club Berlin in der Marienstraße 11. Ist dann Ende April. Und wir hören uns hier auf dieser Stelle in zwei Monaten wieder. Hier kommt jetzt gleich Flo Heiler mit dem Night Flight. Ich würde vorher noch hinweisen auf den Podcast. Der erscheint im Laufe der Nacht auf fritz.de und dann irgendwann am Laufe der Woche auf chaosradio.ch. Mein Name ist Markus Richter. Ich danke euch fürs Zuhören und habe noch eine wichtige Nachricht für euch. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.